[Music]
unlike a conventional wood stove that
burns firewood a pellet stove uses wood
pellets as fuel
made from lumber byproducts such as
sawdust and wood chips which would
otherwise end up as waste pellets burn
more efficiently and more cleanly than
wood and produce very little air
pollution
[Music]
a pellet stove has an on-board storage
container called a hopper that holds
depending on the model up to 80 pounds
of wood pellets
several computer chips monitor the
stove's heating performance dictating
the rate at which the hopper
automatically feeds pellets into the
stove's firepot
the heat output is manually adjustable
or can be controlled by a thermostat
wood pellets burn far more cleanly than
logs and the fire is smoke-free
wood pellets are made from a variety of
raw materials sawdust wood chips wood
shavings small logs even scraps of wood
left over from furniture and other
manufacturing
these different types of lumber
byproducts first have to be reduced to
the same size and consistency
therefore the first stop is a huge
grinding machine
inside mammoth steel hammers pulverize
the raw material to uniform pieces
the raw material contains about 45
percent moisture so it goes into a dryer
to reduce the moisture level to between
11 and 12 percent
so what was rough raw material has now
been ground to a finer state and dried
but it's still not fine enough
so it goes into a mill which processes
it further until it's roughly the size
of rice grains
[Music]
a feed pipe transfers what is now wood
fiber to a row of presses
these are the machines which make the
pellets
the moisture content of the fiber is
critical
if it's too wet the pellet presses risk
clogging up
that's why each pellet press has a
readout displaying the fiber moisture
level
as an added measure the factory draws
fiber samples and sends them to the
quality control lab for analysis it's
essential for the stability of the
pellets that the moisture be at the
ideal level
excess moisture would eventually
evaporate breaking the pellets apart
so to analyze the moisture content the
lab technicians weigh a sample heat it
to a high temperature to evaporate the
moisture
then re-weigh the analyzer is programmed
to translate the weight loss into a
reading of moisture content
the pellet press is a large drum with
perforated rollers inside
the holes are pellet width two tenths of
an inch in diameter
as the drum rotates the rollers apply
pressure
this compresses the fiber by 400 percent
and extrudes it outward through the
holes
a knife slices the extruding fiber at
programmed intervals
cutting it into lengths of about 1 and 2
10 inches
the compression generates heat which
draws out the tree sap still contained
in the wood fiber
this sap called lignin acts as an
adhesive
locking in the pellet shape
the journey from raw material to pellet
is now complete
the pellets however are still quite warm
and sticky so they clump together
the solution about 15 minutes in a
cooler
as the room temperature air blows
through the pellets cooling and drying
the tacky lignin the pellets separate
from each other
some of the processed raw material ends
up in two fine estate to become pellets
so as the pellets exit the cooler a
vibrating screen filters out this
sawdust-like material
which incidentally doesn't go to waste
the factory uses it to fuel the dryer
the pellets meanwhile proceed to
packaging
it's a continuous system
the machine feeds printed plastic film
around a cylindrical tube forming the
shape of the bag
then it drops in 40 pounds of pellets
and seals the top of the bag
simultaneously forming the bottom of the
next one
wood pellet stoves are fast becoming a
popular means of home heating and
because pellets cost significantly less
than most other types of fuel wood
pellet systems are an emerging option
for commercial and industrial heating
[Music]
you